we know that when we have some substance
in a liquid state it has enough kinetic
energy for the molecules to move past
each other but still not enough energy
for the molecules to completely move
away from each other so for example this
is the liquid maybe that they're moving
in that direction these guys are moving
a little bit slower in that direction so
there's a bit of this flow going on but
still their bonds between them they kind
of switch between different molecules
but they want to stay close to each
other there are there are these little
bonds between them and they want to stay
close and then if you if you increase
the coverage kinetic energy enough or
essentially increase the temperature
enough and then overcome the heat of
fusion we know that all of a sudden even
these bonds aren't strong enough to even
keep them close and the molecules
separate and begin to into a gaseous
phase and there they have a lot of
kinetic energy and they're bouncing
around and they take the shape of their
container but there's an interesting
thing to think about
temperature is average kinetic energy
temperature is average kinetic energy
which implies and it's true that all of
the molecules do not have the same
kinetic energy that you know maybe let's
say even they did then these guys would
bump into this guy and you know the
Coulomb is billiard balls and they
transfer all of the momentum to this guy
now this guy has a ton of kinetic energy
this guy these guys have a lot less this
guy has a ton these guys have a lot less
there's a huge distribution of kinetic
energy if you look at the surface atoms
and or the surface molecules and I care
about the surface molecules because
those are the first ones to vaporize or
or I shouldn't I shouldn't jump the gun
they're the they're that they're the
ones capable of leaving if they had
enough kinetic energy if I were to draw
a distribution of the surface molecules
let me draw a little graph here so on
this dimension I have kinetic energy
kinetic energy and on this dimension
this is just the relative concentration
and this
just you know my best estimate but it
should get you the give you the idea so
there's some average kinetic energy at
some temperature all right this is the
average kinetic energy and then the
kinetic energy of all the but it's going
to be a distribution around that so
maybe it looks something like this
a bell curve and you could watch the
statistics videos to learn more about
the normal distribution but I think the
normal distribution this is supposed to
be a normal so it's just it's smaller
and smaller as you go there and so at
any given time although the averages
here there are some molecules that have
a very low kinetic energy they're moving
slowly or maybe they have well let's say
say they're moving slowly and then at
any given time you have some kit some
modules that have a very high kinetic
energy maybe just because of the random
bumps and and and it gets from other
molecules it's a it's a crude a lot of
velocity or at least a lot of momentum
so the question arises are any of these
molecules fast enough are they do they
have enough kinetic energy to escape and
so there is some kinetic energy I'll
draw some threshold here or if you have
a more than that amount of kinetic
energy you actually have enough to
escape if you are a surface atom now
there could be there could be a dude
down here who has a ton of kinetic
energy but he's going to in order for
him to escape you'd have to bump through
all of these other liquid molecules on
the way out so it's a very in fact he
probably won't escape it's the surface
atoms that we care about because those
are the ones that are interfacing
directly with the with the pressure
outside so let's say this is the gas
outside it's going to be much less dense
it doesn't have to be but let's assume
it is alright so these are the guys that
kind of can escape into the air above it
if we assume that there's some air above
it so at any given time there's some
fraction of the particles of the
molecules that can escape so your next
question is hey well doesn't that mean
that they will vaporize or they will
turn into gas and yes it does so at any
given time you have some molecules that
are escaping with those molecules what
it's called is evaporation and this
isn't a foreign concept to you if you
leave water outside it will evaporate
even though outside hopefully in your
place is below the boiling
temperature or the normal boiling
temperature of water the normal boiling
point is just the boiling point at
atmospheric pressure if you just leave
water out over time it will evaporate so
some of these molecules what happens is
some of these molecules that have
unusually high kinetic energy do escape
they do escape and if you have your your
pot or pan outside or even better
outside of your house then what happens
they escape and then the wind blows the
wind will blow and then blow these guys
away and then a few more will escape the
wind blows and blow them all away and a
few more escape and the wind blows and
blows them all away so over time you'll
end up with a with an empty pan that
once held water now the question is what
happens if you have a closed system well
we know I mean we've all done that
experiment you either on purpose or
inadvertently leaving something outside
and seeing that the water will will
evaporate what happens in a closed
system where there isn't wind to blow
away so let's let me just draw nope -
there you go say closed system and I
have it doesn't have to be water but I
have some liquid down here some liquid
down here and there are some pressure
from the air above it let's just say it
was that atmospheric pressure doesn't
have to be so there's some air and the
air has some kinetic energy over here
and so of course do the water molecules
and some of them start to evaporate so
some of the water molecules that have
you know are up here in the distribution
they have enough energy to escape so
they start hanging out with the air
molecules right now something
interesting happens this is the
distribution of the molecules in the
liquid state well there's also a
distribution of the of the kinetic
energies of the molecule and the gaseous
state just like you know different
things are bumping into each other and
gaining and losing kinetic energy down
here the same thing is happening up here
so maybe this guy has a lot of kinetic
energy but he bumps into stuff and he
loses it and then he'll come back down
so there's you know there's some set of
molecules I do another set of blue these
are still the water or whatever the
fluid we're talking about that come back
from the vapor state back into the
liquid state
and so what happens is this this
evaporation well there's always a bit of
evaporation and there's always a bit of
condensation because you always have
this distribution of kinetic energies
there's some at any given moment in time
out of the vapor above the liquid some
of the vapor loses its kinetic energy
and then it goes back in the liquid
state some of the surface liquid gains
kinetic energy by random bumps and
whatever else and goes into the vapor
State and and that'll the vapor State
will continue to happen until you get to
some type of equilibrium and when you
get that equilibrium at some pressure up
here so let me see some pressure and the
pressure is caused by these vapor
particles over here these vapor
particles right here and that pressure
is called the vapor pressure vapor
pressure I want to make sure you
understand this so the vapor pressure is
the pressure created at and this is at a
given temperature at a given temperature
for a given molecule given temperature
for a given molecule right every every
molecule or every type of substance will
have a different vapor pressure
different temperatures and obviously
every different type of substance will
also have different vapor pressures
before a given temperature in a given
molecules the pressure at which you have
an equal a pressure created by the vapor
molecules where you have an equilibrium
we have just as many things vaporizing
as things going back into the liquid
state and we learned before that the
more pressure you have the harder it is
to vaporize even more right we learned
in the phase state things that if you
put if you if you are a 100 degrees at
ultra-high pressure you would still and
you were dealing with water you would
still be in the liquid state so this the
vapor creates some pressure and it'll
keep happening depending on how badly
this liquid wants to evaporate but it
keeps vaporizing until the point that
that that you have just as much I guess
you could kind of view it as density up
here but I don't want to think you have
just as many molecules here converting
into this state as molecules here
converting in this state so just to get
an intuition of what vapor pressure is
or how it goes with different molecules
molecules that really want to evaporate
so want to evaporate
want to evaporate and so why would a
molecule want to evaporate it could have
high high kinetic energy so this would
be at a high temperature it could have
low intermolecular forces all right it
could be molecular obviously like the
noble gases have very low molecular
forces but in general most most
hydrocarbons or you know gasoline or
methane or all of these things they
really want to evaporate because they
have much lower intermolecular forces
and say water or they could just be
light molecules light molecules you
could you could look at the physics
lectures but kinetic energy it's a
function of mass and velocity so you
could have a pretty respectable kinetic
energy but if you because you have a
high mass and a low velocity so if you
have a if you have a light mass and the
same kinetic energy or more likely to
have a higher velocity you could watch
the kinetic energy videos for that but
something that wants to evaporate it's a
lot of it's a lot of its molecules let
me do it in a different color something
that wants to evaporate really bad a lot
more of its molecules will have to enter
into this vapor State in order for the
equilibrium to be reached let me do it
all in the same color so the pressure
created by its vaporize its evaporated
molecules is going to be higher for to
get to that equilibrium state so it has
high vapor pressure so high vapor
pressure and on the other side if you're
at a low temperature or you have strong
intermolecular forces or you have a
heavy molecule or I then you're going to
have a low vapor pressure for example
like you know I mean
iron has a very low vapor pressure
because it's not vaporizing while I'll
let me think of something you know
carbon dioxide has a relatively much
higher vapor pressure much more of
carbon dioxide is going to evaporate
when you have it well I really shouldn't
use that because you're going straight
from the liquid to the solid state but I
think you get the idea
and something that has a high vapor
pressure that wants to evaporate really
bad we call it we say it has a high
volatility you've probably heard that
word before high volatility high
volatility so for example gasoline has a
higher it's more volatile than water and
that's why it evaporates and it also has
a higher vapor pressure because if you
were to put it in a closed container
more gasoline at the same temperature
will enter and the same atmospheric
pressure will enter into the vapor state
and so that vapor state there's more the
vapor state will generate more pressure
to offset what we'll have to generate
more pressure to offset the natural
inclination of the gasoline to want to
escape than in the case with water now
an interesting thing happens when this
when this vapor pressure is equal to the
atmospheric pressure so right now this
was our closed container and we had some
you know you have the atmosphere here at
a certain pressure and let's say until
now we've assumed that the atmosphere
the atmosphere was at a higher pressure
so it was for the most part keeping
these molecules contained maybe some
atmosphere molecules are coming in here
and maybe some of the vapor molecules or
escaping a bit but it's keeping it
contained because this is at a higher
pressure out here than this vapor
pressure and of course the pressure
right right here at the surface of the
molecule it's going to be the
combination of the partial pressure due
to the to the few atmospheric molecules
that come in plus the vapor pressure but
once that vapor pressure becomes equal
to that atmospheric pressure so it
starts to it can press out with the same
amount of force you can kind of view it
or the force per area so then the
molecules can start to escape I can push
the atmosphere back and so you start
having a gap here you start having you
start having a vacuum I would you know I
don't to use exactly a vacuum but it's
in some oxygen escape you more and more
of these molecules can start going out
and at that point you've reached the
boiling point of the substance when the
vapor pressure is equal to the
atmospheric pressure now just to get a
sense of what all some of this means
let's look at the vapor pressure for
water this is water
right here h2o I should do that in black
h2o and so you see at at 760 so
atmospheric pressure we're in tours now
but that's just a different one 760
tours is equal to one atmosphere so
that's about right number one that's
about right there so it's one atmosphere
so at atmospheric pressure the vapor
pressure at a hundred degrees Celsius
for water the vapor is is at 100 degree
Celsius for water or I guess another way
to put at 100 degrees Celsius you have
760 Torr a vapor pressure which is
exactly the the atmospheric pressure at
a one atmosphere at sea level so at 100
degrees vapor pressure is equal to
atmospheric or sea level atmospheric sea
level and so you're going to boil which
we all know is true and then if you have
at lower temperatures at lower
temperatures your vapor pressure your
vapor pressure is going to be lower than
the atmospheric pressure right let's see
it look here it looks like 300 something
but then what happens if you lowered the
atmospheric pressure enough if you were
to pump air out of the the container or
whatever low enough and then the so if
you brought the atmospheric pressure
down to this vapor pressure then again
you will have boiling and we saw that in
the phase change diagrams that you can
boil something at a lower temperature
if you lower the atmospheric pressure
and that's because you're lowering the
atmospheric pressure to the vapor
pressure of the substance and here's a
comparative chart of a and this is
interesting you see this is kind of a
exponential increase with temperature of
vapor pressure and that's because if you
think about that distribution we did
before this is at one kinetic energy if
you increase the amount of kinetic
energy then your distribution will look
like this if the temperature has gone up
and now you have a lot lot more it's not
just linear you have a lot more
particles that can now escape and have
the kinetic energy to evaporate and you
can see it's this exponential increase
as you increase the temperature now here
is another chart you say where is that
exponential increase go and that's
because this is a logarithmic
you could see the scale it goes on it
increases with with exponentially as
opposed to linearly so it goes from
point 1 to 10 so equal distances are
actually up by a factor of 10 so that's
why you don't see that logarithmic move
but these are just four different
substances propane you see at any given
so let's go for let's go like a decent
temperature let's go 20 degrees Celsius
20 degrees Celsius propane has the
highest vapor pressure so this is one
atmosphere so propane will actually will
actually evaporate will actually boil at
20 degrees Celsius it'll actually
completely boil and go into the gaseous
state because it's vapor pressure is so
much higher than atmospheric pressure if
we're assuming it's we're at sea level
and then you could do that for different
different molecules methyl chloride is
the next one slightly lower vapor
pressure but still very volatile it
would still definitely boil and turn
into the gaseous state at twenty degrees
Celsius if we're at sea level because
sea level is right there and let's see
it at sea level if you wanted to keep
something so sea level is this pressure
if you wanted to keep if you wanted to
keep let's say methyl chloride if you
wanted to keep methyl chloride in the
liquid state or in equilibrium with the
liquid state instead of boiling you
would have to be at least at around what
is this - 25 degrees Celsius in order
for that even a propane even at minus 25
degrees it's still in the gaseous state
because it's vapor vapor pressure is
still higher and then of course that if
you go onto the you know if you butane
for example butane I think is what they
put actually butane is what they put in
I think they put it in lighters but
butane will be in the liquid state as
long as you're at around roughly 0
degrees and in a lighter you might tell
it's in a liquid state they probably
increase the pressure so the pressure
and the lighter is probably something
higher maybe it's maybe it's at 2
atmospheres or something so that the
butane is at room temperature will stay
in the liquid state who knows I don't
what the pressure is in there there's
just an interesting chart to look at
that there's actually a bunch of
different vapor pressures you can see at
atmospheric pressure what's likely to be
a gas or liquid
in temperatures and then you could see
at different temperatures which are the
things that are most volatile and how
much do you have to increase or decrease
the pressure to to evaporate something
or to boil it anyway hopefully you found
that useful vapor pressure it's
something that we encounter every day
and I'll see you in the next video